vamos a resolver la ecuación 2 x 1
esto lo voy a multiplicar por x 4 y todo
esto lo vamos a hacer igual a 0 así que
pausa el vídeo e intenta ver cuáles son
las x que satisfacen esta ecuación muy
bien ahora las vamos a trabajar juntos
esto y tal vez en un principio estuviste
tentado a multiplicar 2 x menos 1 por x
+ 4 pero existen varias formas en las
que se puede plantear la búsqueda tras
solución ahora yo pienso que el
entendimiento clave es que aquí tenemos
dos cosas multiplicadas igualadas a cero
observamos tienes a esta expresión 2x
menos uno que multiplican a esta otra
expresión a x + 4 y esto a su vez está
igualado a cero entonces si queremos que
dos cosas multiplicadas entre sí sean
igual a cero forzosamente una de ellas o
las dos tienen que ser igual a cero es
más déjame reforzar esta idea si yo
tengo por aquí dos cosas que multiplican
me dan a 0 por ven déjame ponerlo con
este color
por b es igual a 0 eso quiere decir que
al menos una de éstas tiene que ser cero
porque pregúntate esto puede obtener el
producto de dos números que no sean cero
y me den como respuesta a cero bueno la
respuesta es simplemente no si a es por
ejemplo 7 entonces la única forma de
multiplicar a 7 por algo que nos dé 0 es
que esté algo sea cero y de igual manera
aún así me fuera 5 por ejemplo entonces
la única forma de obtener 0 sería
multiplicarlo por 0 entonces déjame
escribirlo si tengo la multiplicación de
dos números igual a cero eso quiere
decir que ya sea am
o sea
y déjame ponerlo con su color
p
o bueno puede ser el caso en que sean
ambos entonces también tenemos
escribirlo
ambos ya sea am o b
ambos deben ser 0
es decir la única forma de obtener el
producto de dos cantidades y obtener
como resultado cero es si uno o ambos
productos es igual a cero es más déjame
ponerlo con un rectángulo de color rojo
porque quiero reforzar muy bien esta
idea es muy importante que tú la
entiendas bien y se te quede en el
cerebro así que déjame ponerla así con
color rojo y ahora piensa un poco porque
es esto trata de poner dos números los
que tú quieras y multiplicarlos y para
obtener cero te vas a dar cuenta que al
menos uno debe de ser cero así que vamos
a usar esta misma idea justo aquí porque
aquí tenemos dos cosas multiplicándose
igualadas a cero en este caso podríamos
tomarnos a dos x menos 1 como nuestra am
y x4 como nuestra vez déjame ponerlo
entonces esta va a ser nuestra vez y
tengo la multiplicación de ambos
igualdad a cero eso quiere decir que ya
sean 2 x menos uno o ya sea x + 4
algunos de ellos
debe de ser igual a 0 o ambos deben de
ser igual a 0 entonces déjame escribirlo
puede ser que 2 x menos 1
a esto igual a 0 y en dado caso
déjame poner
en su dato caso x 4 sea igual a 0 x + 4
sea igual a 0 y entonces vamos a
resolver cada una de estas expresiones
para obtener las x el valor de x que
hagan esta expresión 0 y que hagan esta
expresión 0 observa si de este lado
sumamos 1 de ambos lados déjame ponerlo
me voy a sumar 1 de ambos lados entonces
que voy a obtener bueno estos dos se van
y me queda simplemente 2x igual a 1
y será dividido entre dos de ambos lados
dividido entre dos de ambos lados estos
dos se cancelan y voy a obtener que x
toman el valor de un médium cuando me 2
x menos 1 es igual a 0 observa esto fue
simplemente una ecuación lineal y ahora
si esto no te parece familiar entonces
te invito a que vean los vídeos sobre la
resolución de ecuaciones lineales en
lacan academia ok entonces x igual a un
medio es una de las soluciones y ojo
esto es muy interesante porque aquí
tendremos dos soluciones ya que por aquí
qué pasa
si restamos cuatro de ambos lados bueno
voy a restar cuatro de este lado y voy a
restar cuatro de este lado y entonces
estos dos se van a cancelar déjame
ponerlo así y me quedan que x es igual a
menos 4 observa
tengo dos posibles valores de x que
hacen esta ecuación igual a cero ya sea
déjame atraparlo
o sea igual a un medio
o en su dado caso o en su dado caso que
x sea igual a menos 4 y sabes que sería
muy interesante sustituir cada una de
estas dos soluciones en la ecuación
original y ver qué va a pasar
observamos si pensamos primero en x
igual a un medio entonces aquí que me
quedaría me quedarían dos por un medio
déjame ponerlo aquí 2 x
medium -1 ok esto es lo que tenemos en
el primer paréntesis y después
tendríamos aquí un medio más 4 un médium
+ 4 ahora bien 2 por un medio esto es lo
mismo que 1 y 1 - 1
todo esto es 0 así que de todo esto
tengo cero y 0 por esto que tengo aquí
bueno no importa que tenga aquí un medio
más 4 no me va a importar tanto porque
al multiplicarlo por cero
la respuesta me va a dar simplemente
cero así que cuando tenemos a x igual a
un médium esta primera expresión se
vuelve 0 y al multiplicarlo por la
segunda expresión obtenemos de resultado
0 y va a pasar lo mismo con x igual a
menos 4 se observa si ponemos aquí a
menos 4 este segundo producto me va a
quedar 0 y aunque esta primera expresión
no sea 0 no va a importar porque
cualquier cosa multiplicada por 0 va a
ser cero así que ya está bien vamos a
hacer un ejemplo más y para eso voy a
quitar todo esto que teníamos escrito y
vamos a hacer el siguiente ejercicio que
dice tengo la función
si ahora involucramos una función y va a
ser la siguiente
efe x es igual a y supongamos que
tenemos la función x menos 5 esto que
multiplica a su vez a 5 x + 2
de lujo y ahora imagínate que alguien te
piden encontrar los ceros de fx
bueno pues los ceros son los valores de
x que hacen esta función
esta función fx igual a cero déjame
escribirlo nos podemos preguntar por qué
valores
d
x hacen a efe de x igual a cero queremos
encontrar los valores de x que hagan
esta función igual a 0 y se observa
preguntarme eso es exactamente lo mismo
que buscar los valores de x que hagan
esta parte de aquí igual a 0 es decir
vamos a pensar cuando x menos 5 x 5 x
más 2 cuando esto es igual a 0 y si
observas es justo lo que teníamos en la
otra pantalla así que te invito a que
pausa es el vídeo e intentes trabajarlo
por tu cuenta así que aquí tenemos dos
situaciones donde puede suceder que esto
sea igual a cero puede ser que x menos 5
sea igual a 0
esto sería uno de los casos o puede ser
que
x2
igual a cero ok ahora en esta primera
situación ya casi tenemos el valor de x
se sumó 5 de ambos lados voy a obtener
que x es igual a 5 ok y ahora en el otro
caso tengo que 5x va a ser igual a menos
2 si restó 2 de ambos lados y ahora sí
dividido de ambos lados en 35 más
individuos de ambos lados en 35 me voy a
obtener el valor de x de menos 2
500 ya está así que ya sea que x tomen
el valor de 5
y déjame ponerlo así
x tomen el valor de dos quintos para
cualquiera de estos dos valores esta
función va a valer cero
y es que observa si x vale 5 entonces
esta parte de aquí esta parte de aquí va
a valer cero y cero por lo que sea pues
es simplemente cero no importa que esto
me dé 27 0 x 27 va a ser cero y si yo
tomo ahora el valor de menos dos quintos
entonces esta parte de aquí va a ser
cero y no importa que me quede aquí
porque cero por lo que sea me va a dar
cero